[Music]
my next guest is one of the top
Paralympians in the world as she's a
three-time gold medalist and the first
American woman to win gold medals in
both the summer and winter olympics for
wheelchair basketball and alpine skiing
she'll be competing for the US in Sochi
Russia please welcome the incredible
Alaina Nichols
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we have another clip of you one final
clip of you competing which I hear is
quite extraordinary what's going on
well this is actually me more recently
competing at the World Cup level and I
just I think it's one of my best clips I
wanted to show it to you tonight all
right let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I think it very clear you did that to me
did not do that to you you did that to
me I did that to you Conan I've been
watching your show for years Paul Rudd
is one of my favorite actors Paul Rudd
shows that clip every time he's on no
matter what movie he's promoting and how
ridiculous is did you decide to do that
to me I am winning today what's
fantastic
[Applause]